so Tom Cruise
has seen The Flash movie
because he wanted to Tom Cruise Top Gun
Top Gun Maverick the Mission Impossible
movies Jerry Maguire the star of all
these iconic movies wanted to see the
flash so in a conversation with Warner
Brothers Discovery CEO David zasloff
talking about The Flash movie Tom Cruise
was curious and went hey
I want to see this movie and what do you
say when Tom Cruise says I want to see
one of your movies well you say okay so
get this Tom Cruise watches the movie
and then Praises it stating how good the
movie is which makes it even more
exciting for all of us fans to watch
this movie because it's had a lot of
controversy surrounding it for a very
long time what's going on everybody
welcome back to the channel I'm Warren
Thompson and today we have a lot of
great news to talk about including what
Tom Cruise has said about The Flash
movie we have to talk about the new
Superman movie and its director and
release date and of course we have to
talk about James Gunn talking about Ben
Affleck and everybody calling him a
so-called liar we'll break this all down
for you in this video so no I am not
kidding Tom Cruise the man who the
legendary Steven Spielberg said saved
Hollywood with top gun Maverick and
basically he loved it he even called the
director after watching the movie now
this is coming from a report from The
Hollywood Reporter and we're just going
to read it from the website because it's
an awesome article and the story of Tom
Cruise watching The Flash movie is so
great and it gives me a a lot of Hope
for this movie now the article starts
off just by stating some facts about the
movie it states it's June 16th release
date and it does State how James gunned
the new DC co-head called it probably
one of the greatest superhero movies
ever made and with just the first
trailer we can see how that can totally
be possible fingers crossed but it goes
on to say sources tell The Hollywood
Reporter that Cruz has seen the movie
and loved it so much that he cold called
the movie's director Andy muschietti to
Rave about it they stayed in late
February according to several sources
Crews had a meeting with Warner Brothers
Discovery CEO David zoslav during which
the Mogul mentioned how great the movie
was Cruz's curiosity peaked then asked
to see it and as we talked about zazlov
said yes and a copy of the movie was
sent over to Tom Cruise's home the
article continues and says but as an
Insider says this was no casual
messengering a Warner's employee brought
the movie to Cruise's home in Beverly
Hills and stayed until after the actor
had finished watching the movie it is
unclear on what format Crews watched it
whether it was digital or film when Cruz
finished the movie was given back to the
messenger who returned it to the studio
Cruz was so taken by what he saw that
soon after he reached out to mashiri it
was a call out of the blue for the
director Cruz is said to have raved
about the movie saying something to the
effect that flash is everything you want
in a movie and this is the kind of movie
we need now that is insanely High Praise
from Tom Cruise a man who loves good
cinema he said it's a movie that we need
right now so you just have to think that
if Tom Cruise has praised this movie
It's gotta be pretty dang good but now
of course something else that fans are
wondering is what was the meeting about
with Warner Brothers Discovery is Tom
Cruise about to join the new DC Universe
Tom Cruise met with the CEO of Warner
Brothers Discovery and that meeting led
to him wanting to watch The Flash movie
because he was curious about it well now
we're all curious about what his meeting
was about it obviously led to a
conversation about DC and the Flash
which made him curious about the movie
so could Tom Cruise have met with David
zoslop to talk about a possible future
in the DC Universe well we know that in
chapter 1 of the new DCU a lanterns
project is going to be coming focusing
on a few different Green Lanterns well
we know that a long time ago a few years
ago there were a lot of rumors going
around stating that Tom Cruise could be
the next Hal Jordan now at this point in
time we're not sure if there's any
validity to that but that is the first
thing that comes to our head if Tom
Cruise is joining the DC Universe now of
course there are many other roles that
he could play and if you think of one
that you think he would be perfect for
it please let us know in the comments
down below and let us know if you'd be
excited for Tom Cruise to join the DCU
now what could have gotten Tom Cruise
excited about the upcoming projects for
the DCU including The Flash movie which
is supposed to reset the universe what
could have got him excited is maybe they
gave him a little bit of a preview as to
what's to come with their upcoming
projects one of those could be Superman
as it looks like it is gaining a lot of
traction now James Gunn has officially
announced that he is going to be
directing and writing the movie in true
James Gunn fashion he took to Twitter
stating yes I'm directing Superman
Legacy to be released on July 11th of
2025. then he goes on to actually praise
the script that he has so far and he
talks about how the movie is emotional
for him stating my brother Matt told me
when he saw the release date he started
to cry I asked him why he said dude it's
Dad's birthday I hadn't realized and it
goes on to talk about how he is getting
emotional about writing the script and
actually gives us a plot synopsis of
what the movie is going to be about in
the same thread he tweeted I lost my dad
almost three years ago it was my best
friend he didn't understand me as a kid
but he supported of my love of comics
and my love of film and I want to be
making this movie now without him it has
been a long road to this point I was
offered Superman years ago I initially
said no because I didn't have a way in
that felt unique and fun and emotional
that gave Superman the dignity he
deserved then a bit less than a year ago
I saw a way in in many ways centering
around Superman's Heritage how both his
aristocratic Kryptonian parents and his
Kansas farmer parents inform who he is
and the choices he makes so I chose to
finally take on writing the script but I
was hesitant to direct despite the
constant pestering by Peter Safran and
others to commit sorry Peter just
because I write something doesn't mean I
Feel It In My Bones visually and
emotionally enough to spend over two
years directing it especially not
something of this magnitude but the long
and the short of it is I love this
script and I'm incredibly excited as we
begin this journey hashtag up up and
away so James Gunn is already praising
his own script and giving us a little
bit of a tease of what to expect from
the new Superman movie telling us that
Superman Legacy tells the story of
Superman's journey to reconcile his
Kryptonian Heritage with this human
upbringing as Clark Kent of Smallville
Kansas he is the embodiment of truth
justice and the American way Guided by
human kindness in a world that sees
kindness as old-fashioned so it really
sounds like James Gunn is going to be
diving into who Clark Kent really is
which I am personally really excited to
see but of course we want to hear from
you let us know what you think about
this down below in the comments and as I
mentioned we can't wrap on DC news
without talking about the big
controversy surrounding James Gunn and
Ben Affleck lately a lot of people have
heard at this point but if you haven't
it's an interesting story and maybe we
can help shed some light on it back in
December when James Gunn tweeted
announcing a Superman movie is coming he
stated that I am writing and have been
for a while we don't know who is
directing it a Twitter user replied to
him could Ben afflecked directed in
which he replied met with Ben yesterday
precisely because he wants to direct and
we want him to direct we just have to
find the right project so many fans were
really excited about this and kind of
assumed that that right project could
possibly be a Batman movie since Ben
Affleck expressed interest in directing
a Batman movie in the past however in a
recent interview with The Hollywood
Reporter Ben Affleck said that he would
absolutely not direct something for
James gunz's DC he said I would not
direct something for the James Gunn DC
absolutely not I have nothing against
James Gunn nice guy sure he's going to
do a great job I just wouldn't want to
go in and Direct in the way they're
doing that I'm not interested in that so
a lot of people have been calling James
Gunn a liar stating that he lied he
didn't really meet with Ben Affleck
because Ben Affleck just said I don't
want to direct anything he actually said
absolutely not he's spoken absolutes
however here's what we think happened
and what a lot of people are saying
probably happened James Gunn stated this
back in December and mid-December
December 14th this came out yesterday so
three months have passed by including
the release of the first chapter of DC
well actually only about half of the
first chapter of the DC slate has been
revealed so what most likely happened is
that James Gunn did meet with Ben
Affleck they talked about a possible
future but then the entire slate was
revealed and Ben Affleck went no I don't
want anything to do with any of those
projects which would mean James Gunn
didn't why there's probably a lot of
subtext that we don't know about and a
lot of conversations that have happened
in between these three months that have
led to Ben Affleck stating no absolutely
not but James Gunn typically shines
light on situations like these so let's
wait and see if he actually says
something about this situation in the
meantime let us know your thoughts on
the new DC Universe and the direction
that it is going also let us know your
thoughts on Tom Cruise's flash comments
and James Gunn now directing and writing
Superman Legacy please don't forget to
like the video and of course if you want
to stay up to date on the latest DC
Universe News be sure to subscribe to
the channel you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
foreign